vuole fare una confessione questa è la
prima volta che viene data l'opportunità
pubblicamente non di parlare della mia
professionalità di quello che so
riferito il mio lavoro ma di quello che
il mio lavoro ha costruito dentro di me
sono un preparatore fisico da più di
trent'anni allenano atleti squadre al
lavoro per federazioni sportive con
obiettivo principale che è quello di
migliorare la performance e cercare di
ottenere il risultato più importante
quello che è più visibile a tutti
spesso mi si chiede qual è stata la
gioia più grande che abbia mai vissuto
e tutti si aspettano video palle di
vittorie di gesta eroiche di grandi
risultati dei campioni
io oggi voglio parlarvi di qualcosa di
diverso che sta dietro le quinte appunto
ma per me è veramente importante come
allenarsi per essere una miglior
versione di se stesse non per avere
qualcosa per questo vi parlerò di che
cosa lo sport mi ha insegnato di come lo
sport mi ha cambiato del perché senza lo
sport forse non avrei mai superato il
momento più difficile la mia vita lo
sport a volte spietato sembra che ci
siano solo i vincitori quelli bravi e
poi tutti gli altri quelli che ci però
tutto è accelerato in positivo e
negativo
quando si vince quando si perde con la
verità errate
se solo la vittoria l'unico motivo del
tuo percorso sportivo
secondo me vivrai molte più delusioni
che gioie
c'è una frase di churchill che dice che
è successo non è definitivo il
fallimento non è fatale ciò che conta è
il coraggio di andare avanti bene questa
frase assume tutto quello che lo
sporting ha insegnato la performance a
tre volti quello cognitivo quello fisico
atletico e quello emotivo si migliorasse
in grado di disegnare un percorso che li
consideri tutti dandoti delle priorità
ma non deve escludere nulla di avere una
traccia con interventi messi in sequenza
ma allo stesso tempo deve essere
flessibile e devi essere reattivo a
considerare il cambiamento quello
emotivo è forse l'aspetto che
sottovaluta ma avere la consapevolezza
delle proprie reazioni votive riuscire a
controllare grande stress o grandissima
fuori è fondamentale
ecco il preparatore vive tutto
intensamente ma non può mai spegnere la
sua parte razionale
voglio condividere i punti essenziali
del 31 in maniera che mi possa essere
più facile riconoscere alcuni valori
in sintesi cosa significa essere
competitivi allenare avere o creare una
professione riconoscere il valore della
gratitudine della gratificazione e avere
coraggio essere competitivo essenziale
per ogni sportivo significa prepararsi
ad essere sempre vicini alla miglior
prestazione poi perdere una tappa una
partita una corsa ma sai che alla
prossima occasione si può ritrovare la
competizione a valori oggettivi
presuppone un avversario ed è
diversissima dalla sfida personale che
invece alimentata dalla passione per
quello che fa
ecco la sfida è quella cosa che ti fa
alzare prima la mattina che ti dà forza
per ogni rinuncia che fai
chi ti fa essere il primo ad arrivare
l'ultimo andar via e da solo ogni
ostacolo in opportunità perché tu
obiettivo finale sta sempre dall'altra
parte se digitate allenare su google
trovate diverse sfumature tutte però
molto importanti come ad esempio educare
quindi far crescere qualcuno da un punto
di vista morale intellettuale esercitare
quindi tenere in esercizio la funzione
ma anche addestrare rendere qualcuno
abile a qualcosa stimolare corpo mente e
formare dare origine a qualcosa di nuovo
io cerco di allenare seguendo questa
logica educare prima di esercita
stimolare e motivare per rinnovarsi
continua la professione un lento e
logico adattamento verso un obiettivo
alcune volte non conosciamo tutti i
dettagli di un percorso che vogliamo
fare dobbiamo avere la forza di
iniziarlo e la consapevolezza di poterci
riuscire
bisogna imparare ed aver pazienza che
non significa aspettare passivamente ma
agire in base alle situazioni del
momento niente di più
le persone grate apprezzano quello che
hanno invece di lasciarsi ossessionare
da quello che loro esprimono gratitudine
verso le altre persone e per questa
ragione spesso ne ricevono in cambio più
degli altri per caso le grate vivono
ogni nuovo giorno come un'opportunità e
rinforzo positivo e molto più efficace
di quello negativo incoraggiare non
significa semplicemente stimolare
significa attivare un processo di stima
di cooperazione che crea uno stato
d'animo positivo le piccole
gratificazioni hanno un valore immenso
non bisogna mai dimenticarlo e ne
abbiamo bisogno tutti il coraggio sta
nell'imparare dalle difficoltà nel
rilanciare
partendo dal presupposto che noi siamo
ciò che facciamo non dobbiamo aver paura
dobbiamo cambiare la paura con il
coraggio ma questo lo fai solo se ti
laici detto se capisci quello che
desideri veramente se fai questi pax
passaggi anche nel caso di un fallimento
non ci sarà mai nessun rimpianto
ora arriva il momento difficile
raccontarvi un bruttissimo ko a
resistere ad una tragedia che dopo due
anni di lotte aveva completamente
distrutto la mia famiglia
nel 2007 una grave malattia aveva
strappato monica né moglie aveva 44 anni
mamma dei miei due figli marco sofia di
16 di 13 anni in quel momento tutto
quello che avevi fatto che credevi fosse
importante
sparisce ma hai un senso di vuoto e
tantissima paura
ricordo ancora la prima sera senza
monica la casa sembrava enorme il dolore
era enorme sentire quello dei miei figli
nelle stanze adiacenti alla mia erano
strazi indescrivibile quella sera
ricetti un'unica vista quella di rito
mio caro amico la malattia purtroppo
spaventa allontana enrico è medico e
fosse più abituato a certe situazioni e
con la sua semplicità di sempre discusso
ascolta
e normale che oggi tu veda solo quello
che ti manca
grande la tragedia che stai vivendo ma
appena riuscirai prova a pensare a tutto
quello che monica che ha lasciato o se
li troverai delle risposte non aver
fretta il dolore molto ogni dal fuoco lo
devi far raffreddare fai tutto con calma
ricordi che per dare energia a chi vi
sta vicino le devi avere una piccola
dose anche per tempo e ricorda ragione
la vera forza la dimostri paul non nulla
è facile con sembrava per rialzarmi
ho iniziato a pensare cosa cosa faresti
se fossi tu a dover aiutare qualcuno a
risollevarsi da una situazione critica
cosa ti ha insegnato lo sport e intanto
dico di essere competitivi continuare a
lavorare duramente più duramente di
prima pensa quanto la ditta tipo ancora
da per te per chi ti sta vicino alleati
per migliorare
hai un ruolo nuovo diverso maggiore
responsabilità pensa come educare i due
figli a responsabilizzarli ad aiutarli a
raggiungere i loro obiettivi personali
creati una professione una logica cerca
di leggerti dentro senza rivoluzione ma
andando in una direzione scelta chiara
dichiarata di aver gratitudine monica ti
ha dato 20 anni di amore che nessuno mai
potrà cancellare
poi solo a essere grato di quanto
vissuto e poi tutti i giorni vedere
questo amore nella vita di due film il
suo amore e lei saranno sempre lì con te
dimostra coraggio
dovrei fare delle scelte di vita comode
scomode col rischio di sbagliare troppo
e passato del tempo sono stati 13 anni
vi posso dire che tante cose sono
cambiate e successe marco mio figlio più
grande medico vive lavoro in svizzera
sofia laureata in business
administration vive e lavora a milano
io monica siamo orgogliosissimi migliori
sono i nostri trofei e brillano più che
mai
ho imparato che la vita da e la vita
togliere la vita restituisce il 18
ottobre giorno il mio compleanno ma il
18 ottobre 2018 è nata mia figlia
alessia mi accompagna ha dato alla luce
questa splendida creatura dopo un
travaglio di 36 dicono le cose belle
sono sempre faticosi allora riempie di
gioia d'energia la nostra vita è stato
il regalo di compleanno più
straordinario che mai potesse micelli lo
sport insegna che ci si allena si
sacrifica non per avere un risultato ma
per essere risultato il risultato la
bellezza di questo viaggio incredibile e
alla nostra vita